hello guys I'm correct I'm John Oh Wendy
Wendy from Collider videos and the movie
couple channels here she does reactions
on her channel and she definitely knows
Tyrone Magnus Tyrone Magnus I first got
Wendy I was the same day Tyrone met
Wendy and she was blushing and she was
she just couldn't believe that she was
in front of such a beautiful black man
Tyrone is a part of a film that they
just shot the trailer for yeah called
vengeance full disclosure right yes to
get this out of the way I didn't know we
were recording this reaction today and I
actually know the guy who made this
movie so oh so you're gonna be quiet
don't take my opinion for it and I
actually know Tyrone yeah so yeah Wendy
only wanted me I'm really honest we have
a bias you can't insult them yeah but if
it looks like if it looks like [ __ ] Tyra
and I might insult it it might Mike's a
good dude though I think I think he's
got it you see a lot of compounds badass
it'll be good
hey you guys ready for this Tyrone's
feature film Judas I hope he says 1
million subscribers ready guys 1 2 3
good lighting very tense
a teaser trailer oh [ __ ] we just do a
reaction to a teaser for a teaser my god
you tricked me they're not a fan of
doing that I didn't realize was going on
right now
I liked when he opened his eyes legit
scared me I was like okay that's kind of
racist don't you think no I just I think
it's being kind of raised he's like a
big day I'm pretty sure it's because you
said it because of his blackness but if
somebody else had done it with that
intensity I still probably been like has
he acted before
just Tyrone has siren acted before yes
I'm sure he's act yeah yeah he's acted
before
yeah yeah there was no some good at
motivation intensity I don't know if I
want to find out what the motivation is
well I'm John wick it's also like a
religious like lighting is super
stylized like it feels like an
exploitation film totally yeah which is
exciting for me because I'm on I'm about
to finish Luke Cage that's like uh like
Marvel's exploitation chef black
exploitation show and lights location I
love it - I want to see Luke Cage guys
but here's what I say in person yeah I
wanted ice EPs and I want to see if he
can lift me off the ground
buckle in a cage it's all about Tyrone
and Magnus Tyrone you're the new Luke
Cage audition you're the only black
superhero I want to see now I'm assuming
you're playing a superhero in this yeah
yeah I feel like excuse me like a mix of
taken with John wick I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say this because I know if Tyrone
was in the room you might expect me to
say this it does look like it might be
out of a porno explain yourself
this isn't okay do you worry that one
time when you were there for this year
might need more remember I do remember
that one time we saw that weird short
film secret Asian man yes and then there
was a short film before that that was
like exploitation kung fu film the guy
gets a hand job at
yes it's rape [ __ ] I don't remember
it vividly I don't like that oh well but
this is borrowing from me
I could just imagine excellence I just
imagined sexual things are gonna happen
really I don't know it's gonna looks
like his BDSM room Yeah right shades of
magnets over here yeah it's a really
stylized shot like going it's like I'm
gonna come get you no it is a really
cool shot yeah I'm gonna come get you
I'm gonna get you looks like yeah until
I get my 1 million he hates whatever
thing is out of no he's not come on
righteous hateful words very mad when
you mention it a million you've been
saying it for a while in a couple of
years now I suspect he's still not there
that's why I never put it out there
1 million confirmed kid you want to
satisfy us man I want him to be like a
badass and everyone liner is something
that you so we just reacted to a teaser
for teaser does that mean you guys have
to come back on the 18th and react to
the actual teaser well I want to see
what I'm excited for them so like I want
to see what this actually looks like
yeah this is the way marketing works now
you have a trailer for your trailer and
it's a teaser for a teaser yeah it makes
me want to see that trailer so when
Tyrone visited LA this was the very
first thing I saw when I woke up every
single more handing over me looking at
me it's also the last thing I would see
them I would yeah when I close my eyes I
see this if I occasionally got up to pee
and then I would just think better well
just do it here in all sincerity though
Tyrone when he when he was out here to
shoot this he stopped by here I was
I'm about like what he really thinks
with the project and he was telling me
like he really does believe in it and he
really does trust who's the writer the
director of Michael Michael Matteo Rossi
Michael Matteo see that he really has a
lot of facing him too and then it was a
great time on set so in all seriousness
I'm excited for you buddy I hope this
turns out well if not my jealousy will
just leave and I'll laugh at you
cuz I'll have one then nothing really to
Friendship that's how true friends work
and then get ready for the 90 minute
reaction film would you react to Michael
Matteo Ross he's like you can't do that
guys you guys are just using all your
content be the future though because of
how popular things like mystery sense
deer are RiffTrax now if you did movie
commentaries that way where it's
literally like a reaction video but with
the movie playing and then you've got
the three reactors at the bottom and but
you get the director to come in and
react with you that could be you think I
feel like I have a harder time given a
full genuine reaction oh yeah oh yeah
someone's face to trying to face this
Tyrone all right Tyrone if you haven't
seen Tyrone's channel you probably have
you're here and mostly yeah okay so
whatever Tyrone's cool
I'm Greg Rio rejects is us subscribe to
us I'm Wendy and Wendy later she should
go I heard a movie haha whoa you took
care of all the promotion that's a very
efficient I think you done making fee or
unprofessional never and I feel like I'm
like the most professional guy on
YouTube you are I think I had nothing
but like nice things to say all my
things